and it's like damn bro like
where the [ __ ] is the the rage where the
[ __ ] is the anger
like
where is that
[Music]
it's hard it's hard to watch
like in five four three two one what's
up everybody welcome to another episode
of the genius brain podcast we have one
of the most highly requested guests
on this podcast it's china mac i've been
[ __ ] with this dude for a long time
super heavy i got super sad when you
said you're going to quit music
when you announced that [ __ ] i was like
yo what the [ __ ] is going on
right especially because when you drop
that track that's actually probably my
favorite track that you
that you drop not that tough it's a
little different you probably did yeah
yeah yeah yeah but that [ __ ] was a
[ __ ]
banger right and like uh i was shocked
when you kind of came out and you're
like you know i'm done with music i
didn't want to do it anymore
um i mean just to get into that part
what was going on at the time when you
were
you know it's it's it's tough you know
um because
i don't do anything else besides you
know
like entertainment you know music and
content
and um i'm independent i do everything
myself
so you know i bust my ass i make music
i spend countless hours days months
weeks in in the studio um
and then you know everybody gets paid
before the artist
you know um the producer gets paid
before the artist the studio the
engineer
the artwork and then that's just you
know video
and and then that's just to make the
music right
and because just because you make the
music doesn't mean you automatically
start making money you know
yeah now you need marketing now you need
this you need that you need to pay to be
on here and be
so that that becomes like a lot of money
and a lot of times we don't have enough
money for the marketing
we have enough money to make the music
to make the videos and that's expensive
you know
it could go up to like 5 6k for a video
you know one of my videos and um
if it doesn't stream millions of times
you know we don't get any money like
that you know a thousand streams equals
the four dollars
yeah so it's like i was just
i i did the song not that tough i'm like
okay this is a really good song
this is like party song like this you
could play this anywhere
this is gonna go it drops it does
nothing you know
like the video does nothing nobody puts
it up like no no support nowhere you
know
so i'm just like i was just really uh
you know just just i was um
like disappointed disappointed yeah i
was disappointed
and i was just like you know what the
[ __ ] like i'm i'm doing everything
around it just to get money for music
to and i keep on doing it and doing it
and doing it and it's not making me no
money i'm still in a red and i have to
do other things
just to make just to pay the money back
so i was just one day i came from the
studio
and you know the video released and it
didn't even do like 10k in a day and i'm
just like
you know [ __ ] it you know what i'm
saying and i went on my live and i was
just like yo i quit
you know and then and then i just kept
on saying it you know and then i
took off all my music and i was just
like you know what [ __ ] it because i
don't feel like
i'm being appreciated you know what i'm
saying when i put so much into it
and then um i was really about to quit i
was i really i didn't just say it i
really wanted to quit because it's like
you know when you don't get appreciated
for something that you do you know
it's just you know it's it's it's
disheartening so i was just like you
know what [ __ ] it and then i kept on
talking about it
and then um i went on live and and one
of my brothers was like yo you
know um shooter shout out to shooter93
he's like yo bro you know you shouldn't
quit music maybe you should think about
um just directing your
your your audience like you know
concentrating on your core audience
i'm like word and he's like yo i never i
don't have no music on spotify
itunes or nothing i spell i sell my
music directly to my fans
and i made six figures last year or from
just music
that's crazy so i'm just like what and
he's like yeah bro
you know try it out so i tried it out
and i'm in in one week i made more money
than i made in a whole year
isn't that crazy or music that's what
i'm saying like
music versus streams versus selling
directly to my
consumer i made more mute more money
in one week than i made in a whole year
of streaming music that's [ __ ] wild
dude so i was just like you know
i don't need to quit now you know what
i'm saying because now i have an
audience i have
i have you know so instead of chasing
you know people like more people and
chasing the industry
and chasing people to accept me i was
just like yo there's a shitload of
people that already [ __ ] with me you
know
yeah there's a general rule that people
talk about it's like the rule of a
thousand versus a million right right so
you you focus on like the the fan base
that really [ __ ] with you heavy those
are the people that will you know
they're hardcore like they'll they'll
literally die for you if you ask
you know right and i think a lot of the
times what happens is because we're so
used to trying to grab
everybody's attention we kind of forget
to focus on the people that really [ __ ]
with us right
and those people are are out there you
see them in the comments you see
everything else they just don't know how
to do it besides running up the numbers
on youtube and spotify
but when you have like let's say 10 000
people and they do that it doesn't
really do much
i think like the the hard part for some
people on the outside to look at it
right they're like well
you're a [ __ ] rapper of course you
make a lot of money but they don't see
all the hands that it takes to make a
great product right right and so
like for example people like yo why
don't you do more sketches like who the
[ __ ] gonna pay these people
like youtube doesn't i can't monetize
off of youtube anymore like it doesn't
make me money like right before it was
fine i could pay somebody 600 to a
thousand dollars to make a video because
i'll get the return back and then some
but when that doesn't happen i'm just
making these videos which is fun but i
have bills to pay
right and that's the weird part like you
know they say things like sell out
whatever it's like but you're not paying
my bills
right so like if you if you're so that's
like me saying hey
you're a mechanic you know and
you love making cars you love fixing
cars i mean like
so fix my car for free yeah what the
[ __ ] and if you don't you're a sellout
if you want money you're a [ __ ]
sellout yeah like it just doesn't make
sense
it applies like people are so
conditioned to not pay
for content and music that you know
they forget that artists have to eat too
yeah you know what i'm saying
they forget that we also have carnots we
also have family to feed
yeah we also have appetites ourselves we
like
you know besides what you guys you know
probably
like you know some some of y'all might
look at us like super human beings
yeah but we need to eat like steaks and
chicken and
rice and you know soup and [ __ ] too you
know what i'm saying
i mean it's kind of crazy right because
i know a little bit about your backstory
right right not too much
but it's because after you know prior to
what you were doing before with the
whole gin thing that went down right and
your incarceration like
like i grew up a lot of homies who were
kind of doing a lot of dirt and stuff
right
i was never about that life i was i was
i was not that kid
i couldn't imagine what it's like being
incarcerated like that
has been like my biggest fear right as a
kid just because
i learned early on that if you if when i
was hanging out with people that were
doing bad things it didn't matter
if i was a good kid or not if you're
involved in that area
you everybody gets a hit on you that's
just is what it is right like when i was
a kid i learned that real fast
just kicking with the group of people
that did some dirt they saw me there
and they went after me too and i was
just the [ __ ] church kid you know
right just because i grew up around
these people i'm like hey i'm not
that's not me they didn't give a [ __ ]
anymore so it scared me so
i mean you how long was your bid for
um the last bit yeah the last bit 10
years
three months and 20 days i think
something like that
that's [ __ ] crazy man yeah how did
you keep your sanity like 10 years
i mean you know um
it's you know when we let's say
what do you do that's like people like
do you do you do anything that people
are like oh my god i would never do that
like you know like this stand up
stand up maybe i mean do you run by any
chance do you do anything like i do
kickboxing
kickboxing yeah go into a ring and fight
i heard you say that
right people some people would be like i
would never and probably
before you got into the ring you were
probably like scared shitless
like you know you have nervous and [ __ ]
so
but once you did it you're like okay i
could do it
you know and then you keep on doing it
and you you understand that hey
you know you you you actually can do
more than you actually give yourself
credit for
so i'm not trying to equate like going
to prison that's like
you know kickboxing yeah yeah what i'm
saying is like you know
sometimes we say oh i would never be
able to do that right and i was one of
those people like 10 years
i was like i was thinking about killing
myself like you know
um but then once i started doing it it
was just like i
you know but the 10 years wasn't my
first time in prison
okay no it wasn't my first time in the
system like i was kind of like seasoned
already
like i did juvenile time i did like you
know
a year here two years like 18 months
here
oh goddamn yeah so like you know ever
since i was a kid
you know so i was already kind of like
prepped for it and i feel like you know
these juvenile systems and
like you know a lot of the kids are
prepped they're
they're the incubators like you know
like they're prepped
for prison you know and i feel like um
yeah i actually been in the system since
i was a kid
so i can actually see like you know as a
kid
eight years old you know going into my
first juvenile detention center like
group home or something
i could see how the system actually
prepped me
for prison you know um and once i
did once they gave me the 10 years i was
just like i you know
it seemed like a long time but once i
started doing it it was just like i
i mean for people who don't know like
what's what's that like like what's
i mean i only know stories right because
some of like the some like the older
homies like the ogs like going to prison
was a rite of passage like this is
something you had to do
you go in you come back you're better
for it people respect you more for it so
when you do a bid for a couple of years
it's just like yeah no [ __ ] you know
but for you being in that system only
because now i see
when we hear about somebody's past it's
easy for for us to kind of
kind of put somebody into a box right
and then we see you
you speak online you you talk about a
lot of uh like asian hate and everything
else like that you're very well spoken
how does how did you how did you go from
from this life to the next right because
being being in prison is something else
like some people going
they get incarcerated for 10 years
they're a different human being right in
the worst way possible but you seem to
have come out of that
better right um
well i use my time wisely you know like
i
i didn't just like you know some people
when you go to prison you can either
turn it into
um you could turn it to it could be a
prison
where it's like you know you become
either the same person
or worse when you walk out or you can
turn it into a university
right because like you know what
there's no other university better than
a prison
right and the reason why i say that is
because if you
are focused and if you want
to change and if you want to learn
and if you you know
you know if you're just serious about it
there's no college in the world that can
teach you more
yeah because you have all the time you
know like like
even if you go to the best college in
the world right
you have good teachers you know exactly
right definitely
but you don't have all of the time you
know like and
when you do 10 years you have every day
every minute
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah like
you can read whatever books you want you
can read it 10 20 30 40 50 times
you know you can spend a whole year
reading the same book
you know what i'm saying and and and you
know i did that like i didn't spend the
whole year reading the same book but
i read one book like at least a hundred
times before
oh [ __ ] so it's like i had the time
to prep myself when you're in college
you're studying
right but you have a shitload of other
things to worry about
you know you got to worry about you know
partying you got to worry about
girlfriends you got to worry about cars
and whatever else you
you in prison you don't have anything to
worry about it's just whatever you want
to worry about
yeah yeah you know like you don't have
to pay carnal you don't have to pay rent
you don't have to do any of that you
don't have that like
um responsibility your responsibility is
solely just to stay alive
stay out of trouble and study and do
whatever you know
work or you can do the opposite and
spend your time getting in trouble
and like you know doing drugs and and
because
one thing about prison there's a
shitload of drugs available for you
every time hell yeah you know shitload
drugs there's a lot of people that i
know
that turn into drug addicts that weren't
drug addicts before that never even
tried
heroin or whatever else you know it was
being used in prison
but in prison they turn into that you
know because it's available you know
so um i just chose to use my time
to not turn into a heroin addict or not
become
more of a criminal than i already was
you know and just
i i decided to use my time to become a
better person because
you know like there's one thing about
like getting doing
prison time but there's another thing
about like you know we're asian right
so like family is a big thing you know
so there's another thing about like
having your mother come on and visit the
floor and crying and looking at you like
oh [ __ ] you know you have to change
you know and that but they did a toll on
me and i had time to think about it and
i'm just like you know
[ __ ] up like you know i mean i'm
killing my mother slowly
you know what i'm saying everybody gave
up on me except for my mother so it's
like
wow what the [ __ ] am i gonna do am i
gonna just like be a [ __ ] degenerate
in here or am i gonna just
do something about this so i decided you
know
they got college courses you know they
got this they got that
[ __ ] it i'm gonna just spend my time
doing that so the first like two three
years
i was getting in trouble i was [ __ ]
up you know like i was going in and out
the box
you know i cut a couple people i got cut
myself
you know i stabbed a couple people i did
a bunch of you know i was just in that
like because i was just like you know
what [ __ ] it
but then like you know reality hit me
this podcast is brought to you by
bluetooth my friends fellas i know there
are some of y'all out there that don't
feel like a stallion in the bedroom well
guess what no more
because mr floppy man you don't have to
be ashamed of it it's all good because i
got the solution for you
and that solution is blue chew
as the great rapper jay-z once said if
you're having penis problems i feel bad
for you son
i got 99 problems but blue chew ain't
one hit me
ha ha ha hey he never said that but but
you know what i'm talking about
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
tubal form
and at a fraction of the cost blue chews
tablets help men achieve harder stronger
erections
to combat all forms of ed bluechew is an
online prescription service so no visit
to the doctors
to make it all awkward we don't want
those awkward conversations and i hate
it
and waiting in line at the pharmacy is a
[ __ ]
and it ships right to your door so you
don't have to worry about it it's in a
discreet
package son how dope is that listen
we've got a special deal for
listeners try bluetooth for free when
you use our promo code brain at checkout
just pay
five dollars for shipping that's it
that's bluechew.com promo codebrain to
receive your first
month free and we thank blue chew for
sponsoring our podcast
and i'm just like i don't want to die in
prison because i'm seeing 50 year old
people come in to prison with a brand
new number
god 50 years old and you're coming in
with five years six years
ten years it's like the last few years
of your life right yeah what the [ __ ]
i'm just looking at these people they're
taking out their [ __ ] teeth and
they're putting it on the dresser
[Laughter]
he's like yo [ __ ] is this my [ __ ]
future this isn't my future
no yeah yeah yeah yeah you know oh [ __ ]
i was just like you know i can't i can't
i can't go out like this man
and you know my mother pleaded with me
you know she pleaded with me she begged
me
and i was just like you know i i'm gonna
try my best so i i did my
i used my time wisely you know and i
came out
and i'm not gonna say i'm the perfect
person nobody is
but you know i'm doing my best and i've
been doing pretty good so far
yeah you know with um well so how did
you mine
yeah it's yours all right cool so how
did you uh what about your father how
about your like
your parental figures i know your mother
helped you out a lot but what about your
dad was your dad around for you when you
were younger or
no my dad wasn't i mean he was for a
first couple like
maybe four years but even then he wasn't
really there
you know i'm seeing him i grew up in uh
80s
uh for anybody who doesn't know about
like new york gang
chinese gang culture um my father was
a major figure in a flying dragons gang
oh [ __ ] now he was number two man and
oh [ __ ] and the flying dragons and this
was in the 70s 80s
when it was like you know real popping
right
so um you know they were they were a
part
uh if i don't know if you know but
machine gun johnny have you ever
yes so machine gun johnny was actually
uh
like he was my uncle like not my real
uncle but he was okay
you know and he's my father
my father was his right hand man jesus
and um you know i watched all that [ __ ]
as a kid you know like you know i seen
dead bodies when i was like
a kid lying on the street i seen like
you know
i just seen it i seen a lot as a kid
and um my father
basically you know went to prison he got
caught up
and he basically gave uncle uh he gave
um
machine gun johnny in you know he he
he told on machine he became my
informant
you know oh [ __ ] yeah and uh
you know that was something that i had
to deal with as a kid and since
ever since then like because i when i
grew up like coming up
me i was royalty in chinatown like
new york city chinatown i was royalty as
a kid
like everywhere i walked people like i
mean
people damn near through rose petals at
my feet
you know because of who my father was
and who he was aligned to and
you know the the power they had in
chinatown at the time
and so when he did that when he became a
a 2-5 which in chinese that's what we
call
him i'm saying uh he when he became a
rat
um it changed
yeah we weren't royalty no more
you know and um my mother
you know i saw first my mother did a
really good
job and like you know and taking care of
me and also like preserving his name
to me but i saw firsthand how that
affected my mother and how i affected it
you know and we could have died bro like
you know like like
people could have killed us because of
what he did not because of what i did or
what my mother did
and uh yeah so that that relationship
ended there you know and i it probably
it'll probably like i don't know where
he's at now but
i'll probably die like like with that
relationship being ended there
you know so my parental guidance was my
mother
and the streets that must've been hard
for you mom she had to deal with a lot
then well
shout out to my mother that's that's
crazy i had no idea
wait but you wait what but you weren't a
part of your dad's gang then
after that no well you were wait what
what gang were you in go shadow so you
wait isn't that
the rival yeah yeah how'd that work out
wait how did that work out oh because i
was just like you know
i didn't want anything to do my dad you
know he was flying dragons
i didn't want to be in a gang that he
told on everybody
like yeah i joined the rival game and um
i just said you know what i'ma just like
be
opposite from what my father was right
and
you know that's what happened that's
crazy man
right i mean that's a that's a pretty
strong move for for a young person what
age did you join uh ghost shadows for
i was first year in junior high school
so i was maybe like
oh 12. they took you in even though they
knew who your dad was they recruited you
they didn't know at first oh okay they
didn't know they were just recruiting
people in junior high schools
okay right so people will come to the
junior high schools and pick people up
and come up to kids and so this this
dude that was in junior high school i
mean he was actually a senior in
junior high school i was i just started
first year
and um i was wowed like you know
it was like you know it was it was i was
in special ed
special education for like behavioral
problems and [ __ ]
and it was all black kids in my class
and you know i was wild
you know like and he seen that
the asian person that was in the asian
kid that was in the gangs already he was
in um
he was in a senior like you know he was
about to graduate and he comes up to me
one day after school and he's like yo
you want to uh actually i wasn't in
school i ran away from home
and i was just in front of school just
like hanging out and [ __ ]
and i was like staying at my one of my
black friends like
house like stay sleeping in his closet
and [ __ ]
and the dude comes up to me and he's
like yo
you you want to um you want us you you
want to
chill at the apartment and i'm like an
apartment what about me it was like
you know you get get the smokes free
cigarettes free food free free
you can sleep there and all that i'm
just like damn and me i'm going from
sleeping
underneath beds going from sleeping in
closets
going from sleeping like you know
sleeping on staircases until my friend's
mother
goes to work you know sleeping in train
stations
jesus as a kid yeah you know i'm just
like hell yeah
it's like you have a rooftop bed and
food [ __ ] yeah
i do it so i said hell yeah so i went
down to chinatown
and you know chinatown so for a good
amount of years i was removed from it
because you know my mother
because we were hiding from chinatown
like you know we were looked at like
enemies you know what i'm saying for a
lot of people
but shout out to machine gun johnny
because
he people would have killed us bro
people to kill my mother and my
and me no problem you know but
he told the gang members leaves them
alone they don't have anything to do
with it
you know wow i don't know where that man
is right now but when i was in prison he
was writing me and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying he's a good man
bro like he's a good man
and um i was just you know
i had stayed away from chinatown for a
long time so me coming back as a
from junior high school uh i joined the
bayard street gold shadows
okay and uh and yeah and it was
you know nobody really knew who i was at
first yeah
but then like probably like it's
probably like a couple weeks
to people i started saying like oh
that's this kid's son
and i'm and people just started noticing
and [ __ ] you know and i was just like
[ __ ]
yeah you know like i gotta prove myself
you know what i'm saying like so you
know back then they used to recruit
really young kids
like even like 10 11 12 13
and they recruited these kids because
they knew that these kids
wouldn't get in trouble so we could hold
the guns and we wouldn't get
try like you know adults so
you know they had a bunch of kids in
there like when i went in the
in the apartment they had an apartment
for the adults and they had the like
you know the older and they had an
apartment for the kids i went into
apartment for the kids
and uh i was just like you know what a
lot of these kids were scared too you
know
so i was just like you know what i'm
just gonna be the
the wildest [ __ ] god just to
prove like
everybody that i'm not like my father
you know
yeah so every time there was a drill
like there was something going on
i would hold the gun and i shoot that
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
i wouldn't give a [ __ ] you know like i
mean you had a chip on your shoulder i
had a chip i had a huge
ship on my shoulder i had something to
prove and um
[Music]
i just like you know did did whatever
you know it's crazy like i feel like
when you tell these stories right like
it's crazy because i've heard about a
lot of like the chinese mafia and gang
stuff from from
from uh east coast just from like the
west coast homies here right right
because a lot of people understand
that stuff started out east coast moved
over to chinatown in san francisco and
then kind of bled out everywhere else
right so people don't know the origins
like even some of these young cats they
don't know that the gangs they're in
started over there first
right it's mafia [ __ ] 100 years ago
whatever what not when chinese
immigrants first came here
and so like hearing this stuff is wild
to me right like even the names like
this is stories that i've heard of but
you're so close to it so odd to me right
you know what i mean and
you know when i when i hear a lot of
like conversations about
you know because we hear it a lot about
like asian men being weak this is this
they haven't seen the asian people we
grew up with it's like it's such an odd
conversation to hear because when you
hear about these like
the like when you were a young kid right
when they would do the recruiting stuff
the young people were always the most
scariest ones of all
because they always had to prove
themselves they were the ones that are
strapped up and some [ __ ] went down the
young kids were the first one to stand
up and they're the ones that flashed
their piece
right so it was always [ __ ]
frightening like i still remember the
first time i was at a party and i just
got invited because i grew up with these
kids but i wasn't a part of the gang
i just had a house party some [ __ ] went
down everybody stood up flashed a piece
i was like yo what the [ __ ] is going on
it was frightening [ __ ] right these are
usually like the asian male figures that
i grew up around right so when you hear
this rhetoric of like
the submissive quiet asian it's like
right well maybe you didn't grow up
around the same asian people you grew up
around you know
it's a different story you know right
especially for you and your life you
know like i it's kind of crazy like
like your backstory is so fascinating to
me
like just to see somebody who kind of
grew up disadvantaged
in a way right right like you you grew
up on the other side
right and for you to be able to take
your time in prison and kind of
come out of it and maybe it's because
your mother figure in life who kind of
really
begged you said like hey like you can't
live like this like i want you to get
better was she
was she the main reason for your change
then absolutely
if she wasn't there i would have been a
different person
you know i probably died in prison or
something
i probably came home and like you know
chose to do something else yeah you know
but you know she she she stuck through
me like she stuck with me
only person that really did that really
did
you know and uh yeah she's absolutely
the uh the person to
you know give credit to for the change
that's crazy isn't it though it's like
everybody else disappears and that one
one important person you like can really
kind of set forth like a positive change
because even in my life like my my dad
and i didn't really get along but my mom
was the one that i was like pushing me
like you can do what you want like i
like i believe in you you can push it
and
everybody else like you know when an
asian kid like a korean kid wants to do
comedy for a living instead of going
to college like they're like what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah you know you're
not gonna
you know [ __ ] idiot my mom's like
you know what just just say yes but do
what you want
you know like because she always gave me
the best advice she goes after after
everything's said and done your dad's
gonna die i'm gonna die and you're gonna
be left with your personal choices
that's it like gangsta yeah like you
have nothing else like when i'm gone are
you going to live by the life that i
told you to live and then you're unhappy
just be happy do what you want you know
just be smart about your [ __ ] and so
i decided to pursue what i wanted to do
and it's so great that our that our
mother figures are so strong enough to
do that
that's why you always had a problem when
like people would talk about like oh
asian women are like super
submissive and weak i was like well you
never saw my mother right you know she
was the one always holding it down
my mom was a gangster i seen my mom
[ __ ] a lot of my aggression comes
from my mom
[Laughter]
[ __ ] i see my mom like as a kid she came
out of the car with
like a [ __ ] uh uh the club
oh my god if she's [ __ ] like you know
fighting people with the club like
bro rage that's [ __ ] wow man yeah
so how'd you how did you start going
from this like out of prison and were
you working on music while you were
doing your bid for like
yeah i was always like into music and
[ __ ] you know like as a kid
it was really like being like the only
asian kid
and a group home in a juvenile detention
center
uh i had to find something to like you
know
like to
just like relate to the kids that was
there because they were all like black
kids and [ __ ]
yeah i mean because you could rap like
right it's not like some [ __ ] where it's
like
like everybody got a different taste for
rap or whatever but you could like rap
rap
right yeah and it was my rap comes from
like older school
like you know the first hip-hop person
that i really listened to was kuji rap
i'm pretty sure like a lot of people
that's watching this podcast don't even
have an idea what gucci rap is you know
like krs-1 like you know around that
time so like you know my music comes
from
that cloth of rapping like
you know cause like the difference is
too is like from what i see in your
music too especially when i
saw you drop not that tough like you
have an understanding of music it's not
just like you know real rap raw but
you're just going off hilarious lyrics
lyrics like
you wrote a dope hook it made sense and
the music rhyme scheme is really good
which is actually something people don't
understand there's a lot of people who
can rap
but there's a lot of people who can't
create music though right those are two
separate things like you'll hear dudes
who can freestyle like crazy but you put
them on the track and they don't know
how to make a song
i mean for you like how did you get to
understand music so well
i don't know it's just like i've been
around it for a while you know so like
my type of hip-hop
is like different than a lot of young
people's hip-hop because my hip-hop came
from like
new york and it was like around that
time
like i wasn't around with new york like
when hip-hop was
founded but it wasn't that far away
yeah so like i was i come from that
lineage
of hip-hop that like real true
lyricism hip-hop like you know how to
tell a story
with with hip-hop with music and how to
like
you know so that's where i learned my
music and
you know that's how i you know it's
carried through
all the way all this time and i decided
to do music because it's like you know
i was in prison i was just like oh well
what am i going to do when i get out of
prison like
you know once i reach my like sixth year
i'm like damn i got like four more years
ago you know
i'll probably be i'll be home soon so
what am i gonna do
like you know yeah am i gonna work for
somebody and i know what type of
character like you know
what type of person i am i was just like
damn i don't like working for people
because i hate listening to these
[ __ ] officers telling me to [ __ ]
sweep the floor
like [ __ ] you know do this do that
and it was like
you know and i knew that if i were to
like come home and work for somebody i
probably would end up going back to
prison because i probably end up doing
something else
so i was just like you know i love doing
music
and i was known throughout prison for
rapping and [ __ ] like every jail i went
to people knew me
oh like the [ __ ] the rapper the asian
rapper
i used to battle people in the middle of
this the [ __ ]
yards and you know you can fact check me
like you know
there's people like that talks about it
like i used to battle people
like in the yards and the whole [ __ ]
yard would stop and just watch this
battle
you know like people stop would stop
playing basketball the officers
would stop whatever they're doing and
the whole yard would just come
around us in the middle like and me just
in the middle battling somebody and i'll
be like you know what
i battle you for your sneakers you know
and if
and if i win you got to take your
sneakers off and your socks
and you got to walk back you got to walk
back to
your house you know not to your to your
cell block
barefoot and it wasn't like a walk like
you know like a one minute walk yeah it
was like
woke up a tunnel woke up stairs woke up
a hallway
woke up you know in the block woke up
galleries and stairs and [ __ ] like that
it was like a long walk
it was probably like a [ __ ] 15 20
minute walk
god damn barefoot and your boy
china mac used to make people walk
barefoot back
to their [ __ ] cells that's crazy man
yeah i lost
too you know but you had to make that
walk too but it is what it is no i never
made that walk okay
i would just say yo i got 10 [ __ ]
packs of new ports for your sneakers
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know and a lot
of people didn't have like 10 packs of
new ports or 20 packs and of course
but if you didn't have you know
cigarettes then
i i battered for you for your shoes you
know yeah like what's up
and then i used to love that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] used to like make my [ __ ]
used to make my [ __ ] dick hard
yeah it's just tight man i mean you
definitely i think that's the cool thing
is like
creative people can always figure out a
way to make their lives entertaining
right and and like if you were in that
position i think that you would be able
to find a way
through it by your jokes you know i hope
so i'm not trying to get [ __ ] with no
i'm just saying like
you know like we find our way we use our
like creativity to find a way you know
what i'm saying i use my
music and [ __ ] you know and um
yeah so i mean you know like for your
whole life like do you do you ever
regret certain choices that you've made
in the past like i only asked this
because
you know this is a question that a lot
of people ask me right they go like what
are some of your regrets
and sometimes i feel it's hard to say
because a lot of these mistakes that we
make
kind of make who we are now right like
the stories that we have
the things that we get to share and
sometimes
in my personal opinion you need some
people to make those mistakes for you
so you don't have to make it yourself i
just regret the time
because you can't get that back you know
yeah so like
i regret like you know i spent my whole
20s in prison
i can never get those 20s back you know
so yeah i learned a lot during those
years but
also i can never like you know i never
know what it's like to like
be a kid on college campus or like you
know
even though i did experience it a little
bit but not really
i wasn't the kid on campus i went to
somebody else's college or what
but uh i would never know
how that feels and i would never know
you know certain things so my whole 20s
was just in prison
so that's the only thing that i regret
like that
i waste the time that i would never like
get back you know and that that's it
other than that like i learned a lot you
know like i am who i am
because of what i went through
so i don't regret that yeah yeah was it
was it crazy for you when you did that
video
with with jen like when you when you
dropped that video i was like yo what
the [ __ ]
right you know because that that's
that's some wild [ __ ] to me because i i
actually didn't know
what the whole what you what you did
what you did your bid for i didn't know
what it was about
right and then when you dropped that
video it it was
i can't remember it too well now but
like it was but you weren't there for
jen it was for something else it just
happened that way
right yeah i didn't know jim was gonna
be there
yeah um
yeah it's just i didn't know jim was
gonna be there but when i saw him you
know
due to other circumstances and you guys
can watch the video
yeah i don't want to see him and just
tell the whole thing but you guys can
watch
the uh the interview with me and jim
where i talk about the whole thing
me and jin talks about the whole thing
but it was just a [ __ ] a [ __ ] up
situation
you know for everybody you know um and
i made a decision that night that
changed my life you know that changed
everybody's life
and that that was involved and uh
you know it was just it was just
i'm blessed you know i'm blessed because
i didn't kill him yeah if i killed him i
will i probably wouldn't be sitting here
right now or i'll probably be out like
maybe in like another 10 years yeah
right
uh but i didn't kill him but i did try
to kill him
you know like i wanted to kill him i
don't know why
you know but i was i was aiming for his
head i
tried to shoot him in his head the gun
jammed and i ended up shooting him in
his back
which you know didn't uh kill him
and this wasn't jim this was you know
his partner i mean
somebody that he was with that day and i
look at that and i'm like [ __ ] like it
was so easy
for me to kill him like it was the [ __ ]
like i had that [ __ ]
i had the gun pointed to the back of his
head like where the top of
the spine is oh [ __ ] and i pressed it
and uh and i like the gun
jammed oh that's luck right there man
like
that that would have been the one thing
that would have changed your whole life
completely even
even past that 10-year bid that's crazy
i would have did like 25 to life
so i probably been getting out like you
know maybe like
you know another eight years if
if yeah if i had 25 of life i damn sure
wouldn't have been going to college and
[ __ ] i would have been
really like i would have made my name in
prison
like what's the point like another five
eight years ten years
yeah so that 25 to life would have
probably turned into
35. can you imagine yourself
like being that type of person again
because you seem so different now
right like you you you've learned your
lessons you've kind of like upgraded
your life
when you look back at something like
that how does that make you feel
it makes me feel like you know
i mean it makes me feel like damn
i [ __ ] up you know and
i i i did [ __ ] that really didn't
it didn't quote full but that was my
life at the time people were stabbing me
and [ __ ] like shooting at me like you
know
like yeah yeah like you know like i i
didn't
i i shot that wasn't the you know that
wasn't the first
violent incident i had you know but way
before i even shot or stabbed anybody i
was shot and stabbed
i was shot at instead like you know so
like you know
and then and [ __ ] i was just like yo
it's either me or them the [ __ ] and
it's not gonna be me [ __ ] it's not
gonna be me so i'm gonna just
i'm gonna do my thing you know and
that's how i was living for a long time
was the first time you got you got shot
um i got shot
well i got shot at the first time was
i don't know i was in a group home in
bronx in the bronx
and i was like you know we was in
a part of the bronx called gun hill gun
hill road like so
more towards like uh one area but then
we walked to them
so everybody in the group home walked to
the movie theater
uh by was it called it was called
um i forgot
but it was like a mall like a mall area
where the movie theater was and we had
to walk probably like 30 minutes 40
minutes to get there
and people noticed i guess they saw you
know somebody we was walking through the
parking lot and there was i was the only
chinese kid there everybody else was
black
and people was like yo
noticed us from the schools like some
one of the kids had beef
with because it was like section like if
you're from this section
if you're in this school then we so they
were beefing
in the school and when we were walking
to the movie theater
somebody saw that one of the kids was in
school so
when we got into the parking lot you
know the car
came around and just started shooting at
us
oh my [ __ ] god dude your life bro
it wasn't an asian beef it was a [ __ ]
you know it was
it was it was a bunch of it was black it
was black people like you know what i'm
saying and i was
walking with them and they started
shooting boom boom boom
none of us had a gun and i [ __ ] ran
behind a car and [ __ ]
you know and i was like i was just like
damn
one of the kids got shot in the leg you
know what i'm saying and
we were like we were kids so i'm just
looking at this [ __ ] like [ __ ]
oh like you know so i'm looking at like
damn
like life is like it's just the value of
life
just wasn't really that it's that's
[ __ ] crazy man
that is nuts how old were you then
i was like 12 um
yeah i was like that happened right
before i joined the game
oh my god dude like yo i'm listening to
this [ __ ]
my ass is sweating like i'm literally
just walking to the [ __ ] movie
theater and then you get shot at and
it's like
and this is this you know what the
interesting is like this is what i kind
of want people to understand too when
sometimes people look at the value of
somebody else's life they only based it
on the life that they got to live
right so we had a conversation earlier
while i was talking about somebody that
i know
and we were talking about asian violence
and stuff like that like people being
very violent towards asian people and a
buddy of mine talked about hey you gotta
learn how to protect yourself
and the other guy was saying well what
do i need a gun for why do i need a
fight
it's like i've never had to do it my
whole life is well because you didn't
grow up in like
your area you know these are these are
luxuries that people
have not everybody sees that same
reality and so sometimes when
i know it's very hard for people out
there who have lived a very nice and
cushy life
but when you see how other people live
you start to understand how they end up
the way that they do
it's easy for somebody to say well you
you just don't live in that neighborhood
like who what the [ __ ] the resources
yeah like how do i get up and leave yeah
you know but these are like very
simplistic
uh solutions that people have right i
mean when you grow up with a [ __ ]
silver spoon in your mouth like you know
you can get up and leave whenever you
want you know what i'm saying but when
you grow up
you know challenged you know and
you you got to get you got to use
whatever
resources is given to you that's a
little different
you know yeah people don't understand
like how it is like i didn't grow up
like that bad and [ __ ] but you know
because of the certain people around i
got in trouble for [ __ ] that
i didn't even do right before i left the
college when i before i went to ucr
which was like super easy to get in at
the same time i didn't apply they just
took me in
my grades were super bad my house got
shut up
because i just hung around the wrong
people right and then that's just
is what it is but that's far-fetched for
a lot of people to say it's like well
you didn't what did you do i didn't do
[ __ ] i was there
they saw my face well you shouldn't have
been hanging out with those people
exactly i was there and then
like there's people i go to school with
and [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
these are just people i grew up with you
know and i didn't know the dirt that
they were [ __ ] doing and
we were kicking it next thing you know
they followed me home they shot at my
house right what was what
so what happens here you know a lot of
people don't live in those type of
realities that's why
when we talk about uh standing up for
yourself
and kind of making them know that you
can't be punked it's very important
because you have to be your first
responder
right it's the hardest thing to watch i
know i know we're not talking about like
some of these older asian people like
they're gonna
they're old but when you see it you
should be able to help out i think
that's the hard part for me sometimes
like
when i see some of our our elders get
attacked and then i watch people just
watch
that's the hard part it's like i went on
my live yesterday
i was really pissed and i said you know
i said that
i said that yo i'm ashamed of being
chinese
because and i love being chinese i'm
[ __ ] my name is chinamax
like i'm proud of who i am but the way
like
i saw this video yesterday where
on my block on bayard street
a block that i grew up on a person
just sucker punched a asian woman
like unexpectedly you know
and i saw like you know
men on that street just didn't even
[ __ ]
get up bro he didn't even get up
she pissed me off bro
you know to see that we would just allow
some [ __ ] like that to happen
it's [ __ ] up
and it's like damn bro like
where the [ __ ] is the the rage where the
[ __ ] is the anger
like
where is that
it's hard it's hard to watch
like i actually just saw that video
before you came here you know
and uh i think this is what i'm talking
about where
i i understand that a lot of people
you know they're not going to be like
maybe how i would handle the situation
where i come up and i'ma grab somebody
and then [ __ ]
you know do some [ __ ] i think the hard
part is is like
you watch that and you see they just
watch it you know
and you know i think you're really close
to your mother you see a older woman
like that it reminds you
of your parents and what would happen to
them when they just sit there and people
watch and they do nothing
the hard part is is like i don't know
how to
kind of translate this out to people
it's like you don't have to do it how
the way i would do it
right but you have to do and say
something to watch it happen it's hard
you know and for us it's like what what
what
message do we need to get across to say
hey when this stuff happens
you we have to come together as a
community and help each other out
it's hard watching those videos you know
yeah i got you man
damn yeah
yeah i've been crying so long
is this like one of those reasons for
like i mean your voice is being really
hurt now in this community
right and i think like is it though
i i think it is though like here's the
thing
here's what i appreciate about you a lot
right there are people in our community
that are not like us right they have a
depiction
of what it is to speak up for things and
the way that they do it
right but there are more p there are a
lot more people that you realize
that need your voice than those other
people because a lot of people who do
the whole you know like hey let's get on
a stream together and talk about this
type of stuff right
but there's also people like you who
speak up and say hey
we need to rally together and show
strength in numbers and your voice is
very
very important it may not seem like it's
sometimes because
you know some of these like cleaner
celebrities go out there and they talk
their [ __ ] about experiences that
they don't know what it's like
right but when you speak about your
stuff you do reach an audience that
those people can't reach
it's like when i was younger and i was
doing my videos right i wasn't the
typical asian kid that most people
expected
and so i didn't get millions of views
like everybody else did who did clean
content but i affected this
the small people who were there to
listen and that's what your platform is
there for
right you reach an audience that they
can't relate to those
this is how i call i call myself a trash
asian right i'm the trash agent that
connects to these other trash agents
because they aren't a part of that crowd
so that's where your voice is very very
important
you know sometimes when they see this
anger they think like oh you're just
angry just to be angry it's like no
no no you you can deal with your
situation how you see fit and i'ma deal
with the way that i see fit
because everybody deals with it
differently and so that's why your voice
is important in the space as well
you know yeah
i i feel like
i'm drowned it out you know i feel like
uh and i'm gonna say this not to like to
my own heart
but just to like raise awareness to what
we're talking about
there was no other asian person well at
least that i know of
talking about the attacks on asian
people before i said anything
you know i i know of right well at least
to do a [ __ ] rally
i know i'm pretty positive within my
time
frame this time frame uh
i was the first person to
to assemble a rally for
uh asian attacks
when i did that no other asian people
wanted to back me
you know no asian people no other asian
person wanted to repost it even in their
story
you know that's eddie wong
that's aquafina that's uh
that's jeremy lin that's ada ryzen
all of them that's dumbfounded that's
all of them
nobody wanted to
you know wanted to back that
for whatever reason you know and i was
upset at that
because it's like damn y'all
like i understand him for like you know
i'm not asking you to share my [ __ ]
music video
you know like i'm asking you to share
something that's affecting all people
you for me and it's like damn you know
like
it's just really disheartening to see
that you know and
and i did it did it without the backing
of anybody
we did it and uh
you know
to see that when we were the first ones
to do it
and then other people come after that
like
several months after once it becomes a
like
you know daniel wu was the only person
that
that really backed it you know uh
to see other people come step in
afterwards
and just you know kind of like it was
like a cleaner cut
image and whatever and then people just
you know kind of like
all right and then get me
and whatever me and who all the people
that were with me
what we did we get slept under the rug
right
nobody even talks about me or
whatever happened nobody even like
we i i don't get the credit you know
other people get the credit
you know why is because it wasn't cool
then right it wasn't cool then
it wasn't cool then and this this but
it's okay for that like i don't i'm not
i'm not i'm not like you know i'm not
bitter about that
i really i'm really not bitter about
that no it sucks though it still sucks
but it's just it's just like
you know this is how
this is how you know we treat
our own people that may be a little
different
that may be different than us but this
is how we treat our own
our own that would like you know these
other asian people that are talking and
the the people with more clean cut
images the people with
more like following and more like money
behind them
they're not willing to bleed in the
streets yeah
i am i was willing to bleed that day
that i started the first rally
i was willing to bleed the second day
the rally in la i was ready to bleed
when i went to san francisco i knew that
the [ __ ] could get crazy i was ready to
bleed i don't think
other people felt like you know like
that it would get crazy but in my mind i
thought it could get crazy i was ready
to
bleed go to jail i was ready to do all
that
you know and i still am for for for the
good cause of our people
you know because i bled and went to jail
for
way less important [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
and it's just it's just like
you know i don't feel like
i don't feel like it's appreciated you
know
i i definitely understand where you're
coming from you know i think the biggest
differences between you and a lot of
other people
you you act and behave out of how you
feel like here
a lot of the people that you listen and
name they're
caricatures they're not about that life
i've i've come to understand that too
there's a reason why my channel is not
as much popping as everybody else's you
know a lot of people are actually afraid
to come on this podcast
because the questions i ask right
because they're expecting me to boost
their [ __ ]
you know morale or whatever but you know
you know me like we got no camera man
this is just a camera a mic
and we got drinks and we're breaking
bread that's about it you know the
differences between those people that
you name they're so worried about who's
gonna come and take [ __ ] out of their
pocket
that they're gonna wait for it to be
popular first right right it's it's easy
for them like i've had people come on
this podcast and they'll ask like hey
can i
these are location people right and it's
like someone like yo can we take this
and that out of the podcast i don't want
no no no this is not how this runs i ask
you at a time is there anything you want
to talk about
if you spoke about it then you know
stick with it you know what i mean
like be real about stuff a lot of people
are not like that
it's what i'm starting to find out
they're so worried about pissing off an
executive
they're so worried about somebody else
that's gonna take their paycheck away
that they won't do things that are right
simply because it makes them look bad
right like for example like like
and even when i talk about asian films
like we mentioned eddie huang right i
[ __ ] hated boogie
and i said that openly i didn't think it
was a good film
you know i i most people won't even say
that
just because they're like oh well you
shouldn't say stuff about like people
who are prominent
i still have an opinion doesn't mean i
[ __ ] hate eddie huang but i'm still
going to talk about the film the way i
want to talk about it
you know and that's that's where
sometimes people
i think people like me and you feel like
we're drowned out right because we don't
play by
certain rules but i do want you to
understand that even though they have
their
the the young people that way there is a
huge crowd that needs your voice
because they don't relate to those
people they 100 do not relate to them
because they don't grow up like how you
grew up you you speak to a people that
needs
your specific voice it's very [ __ ]
important because they can't reach them
it's impossible
because they're not about that [ __ ]
life right like i'm i'm super cool with
like uh
like my buddy phil and wes and they're
part of this film crew called wong fu
right
but they're not a part of my crowd they
didn't grow up like the way i did they
didn't grow up with the people type of
people i grew up
i [ __ ] with them heavy i like them but
my audience generally doesn't really
[ __ ] with them
right but we both live in this space
that's how important your voice is
it's going to happen a lot the clean cut
people will always get
the bigger corporate crowd right but
there are people out there who are at
that rally ready to support you
right and it's there because if you
didn't do that nothing would have
happened it may not
yo you know it was crazy is like
there's a bunch of rallies [ __ ] load of
rallies going on
nobody calls me bro really nobody calls
me like
you know nobody reaches out to tell me
to pull up
and [ __ ] like that you know what i'm
saying and um
it's okay you know i don't i don't i
don't like
but it's just like damn
like i just don't understand it you know
and i went through that all my life
you know you're intimidating dude i went
through that all my life because asian
people like
you know looked at me like
i wasn't asian enough and i always hung
around like
black people spanish people different
types of people
and i always had to deal with that but
you know
this isn't the first time i stood up for
asian people yeah i used to stand up for
asian people all the time
in prison juvenile whenever there was
asian people
like i always stood up with them to
photo even if they didn't
speak english even if they looked at me
like i wasn't really chinese or if i
wasn't really asian
you know i always stood up for them
i always will you know because it's not
about
it's not about how they feel about me
it's about how
we look to everybody else you know
a lot of it's because like they have an
idea of who they want to represent their
group
and it's never going to be people like
you it's not going to be people like me
there's a bunch of like these these like
[ __ ] formal events i'm never invited
to and i'm
one of the bigger names out there right
but once again it's because
this mold that they expect because it's
funny because they talk about like
oh asian people aren't a monolith
meaning like we're not we're not just
one type of way
but when you have these bigger platforms
they don't invite people like you right
they don't like people like me
because they're like we don't fit into
that certain mold it's it's hypocrisy
it's it's really hypocrisy is what it is
like okay well they can't represent
but this is what i was talking about
earlier where people want to put you
into a box in a hole
they hear about your past story your
past life and they go why would we want
china mac around here right it's like
well
you do need him you do need him because
you don't represent the people that he
represents and those people are people
too
that's the hard part right they it's
it's it's
weird how everybody is so outspoken
about not judging people for
kind of like their exterior and what you
might perceive them to be but we do it
all the [ __ ] and they do at the same
time yeah right
they do it they do it to people like you
all the time despite the fact that
you've shown
reform the great things that you're
doing right now it may not be in the way
that they want
right especially when i do these videos
and i'm over like yo [ __ ] you whatever
whatnot come say [ __ ] whatever
most people everybody's like yo that's
dope but there is that fat
their fat group that's like you know you
shouldn't talk like that you shouldn't
say [ __ ] like that
well well i'll do my [ __ ] the way i want
to you do your [ __ ] the way you want to
you know and i'll affect my group the
way i want and you've affected your
group but we're still doing the same
cause
still the same thing right you know
right you know because i feel like
you're you're doing great work like it's
it's it's kind of crazy
like it's true i didn't see anybody
doing any rallies aside from you
right it's it's pretty nutty you know
and and then now you know you got
rallies every [ __ ] week and people
like
just they won't even
they won't even mention my name yeah it
is cool
i i i'm not bitter about that like i
said but
i'm actually done with the rallies yeah
and i said that yesterday in my life the
rallies aren't doing anything but just
like
you know it's it's not doing anything
because
the attacks are still happening you know
and it's going to keep
continue happening so like what the [ __ ]
are we rallying for like are we rallying
to like
you know like people saying my message
is violent my message is too aggressive
the people that are attacking us don't
understand
like you know logic
they don't understand hey let's talk
about this you know
they understand violence you know
and and and i just want to make it
really clear
the people that are attacking these
innocent women
elderly grandparents they're getting
caught
i i don't i think there's probably like
uh
one handful of people
who are not getting caught for these
type of crimes people are getting caught
but it's still happening the next day
the same day you know
so
how can we talk to people that don't
want to be talked to
how can we talk to people that don't
want to talk
you know and that's what i learned
in my environment can't talk to people
that don't want to talk
you know when i was a kid i was getting
harassed
daily in these group homes and
institutions
i was getting my head smacked i was
getting toothpaste put into my hair
i was getting [ __ ] pissed in my
sneaker
i was getting punched i was getting
called every single name in the book
and i tried to talk but nobody
nobody wanted to talk until i started
punching back
until i started fighting back until i
started
as soon as you say king before you can
even say chong
my fist is in your mouth you know what i
mean and that's when it stopped
that's when it was like
i you know so
we we can't reason with people who
doesn't want to be reasoned with
we can only you know
we can only like show them that we're
not
gonna take it so that that's my that's
my stance
like you know my stance is hey you know
there's a time for peace
is it time for for for uh
for talking you know there's a time for
or common sense you know and it's a time
for violence
i i i mean i i agree you know there are
like for me i'm i'm kind of like
you know and we're just to like clarify
i feel like what you're saying is
there's situational [ __ ] there's no
one's complete answer for every
situation right
right well when like i was saying
earlier when
when things happen to you right somebody
comes up and they put their hands on you
you going up into a ball waiting for the
cops to come will do absolutely
nothing i'm not calling for pure
violence but just like that when i was a
young kid
and i used to get bullied i made sure
that i was the hardest person to bully
and
stop because it's annoying it's not
nobody wants to [ __ ] with somebody
that's always willing to fight back
yo listen i'm not telling anybody to be
violent bro but if you're gonna [ __ ]
stand there
and watch a [ __ ] 50-year-old woman
get punched
and you don't do nothing you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you're a [ __ ]
all of these [ __ ] asian blog sites
that just keep on posting videos of us
getting [ __ ]
hammered and [ __ ] like and and beat
the [ __ ] up
and doing nothing at like like
nothing else behind it y'all [ __ ]
you know like like
i just see so much [ __ ] like people just
trying to continue the division
you know like i grew up around black
people
you know i've never really experienced
hate from black people
yeah i've experienced bullying from
black people
i've experienced you know stereotypes
from black people like i experienced
like
[ __ ] like that but not hate you know and
i've been around black people in my life
yeah and what i see now is like
these these blog sites
black blog sites asian blog sites all
types of different blog sites
everybody is pushing division
everybody's pushing hate i've
i'm seeing more hate now than i've ever
seen in my life
you know in terms of racial [ __ ] you
know
and um i think
all these sites that just keep on
posting videos of us getting beat
is just doing nothing but scaring our
people
and inviting other people to come
[ __ ] with us do you agree this is how i
feel i feel like since
everybody's i've been calling it trauma
porn like people are
into trauma you know and the more these
videos have been rolling out
the more this [ __ ] has been happening
it's like
okay if you're going to highlight this
stuff too right you got to show the
opposite as well
right with like and and on my asian
where the [ __ ] are the videos
of us fighting back yeah where are these
videos
like i i just i would get on my knees
and beg y'all like
you know like where are these videos bro
like why is it just
videos of us getting attacked and beat
the [ __ ] up and
us just like holding our balls in our
[ __ ] hand like
like like
it's really exhausting it's really hard
bro like to see our people go like that
like
to go out like that like you know like
i know a lot of us aren't grown up like
that we don't grow up like that you know
but tough times require tough measures
you know like we're we need to we need
to think
we need to realize that things are a
little different now
and we need to start adjusting how
we are you know even something simple
like let's say things don't get violent
right but i've been watching these
videos of people like accosting like
asian people right and they say some
[ __ ] and they just stand there
i was like even something simple is like
yo don't [ __ ] call me a [ __ ]
yo no [ __ ] that that video yesterday bro
when that dude just punched that asian
woman there was like 10
20 [ __ ] asian dudes yeah sat there
yeah i'm talking
i i honestly i want to go back to
chinatown i want to smack every single
[ __ ] asian person
every chinese person whoever was in that
video that just sat there
i would smack them just as fast as i
would [ __ ] punch
that dude that did that like like i'm
just saying
like these videos
just show that we're [ __ ] weak
they show they welcome other people
that are mentally unstable
that are looking for uh victims
for opportunity they're welcoming
this [ __ ] to us bro like
it's it's like kind of like like your
point of view is like they're showing
this thing of like
we can do what we want to you and you're
not gonna do anything about it
and that's the hard part for me too you
know like
and i'm talking about situations that
are like non-violent right like these
videos where it's just somebody talking
[ __ ]
it would be not like when because i've
had this comment too where people are
like well
nobody's gonna walk up and just start
fighting people i was like okay cool
i'm not saying that every situation
calls for that i'm saying there's
different situations for something
problem is that when i see videos i see
interactions of like
you just standing there and just taking
it and not doing anything
that's where it's problematic for me
something that's simple if it's a
non-violent situation right
something is you telling somebody don't
[ __ ] call me a [ __ ] that shows
something
right because most people their [ __ ]
made they're not going to do anything
else after that
but in yours in that situation with that
video i agree with you it was very hard
to watch to watch like six or seven
people
this lady was if you guys haven't seen
this video she was knocked
out cold and she was slumped against
this pole
laying down knocked out and then that
guy stood there i mean he was a crazy
person whatever that's fine
but the fact that they just stood there
and watched him and they didn't do
anything
it was it was so disheartening for me
it's hard to watch
it's really hard to watch and like i'm
saying there's there is no like general
real solution all the time i can't tell
you what to do
but in my situation i don't think i'd be
able just to watch that and do nothing
like it's hard how can you watch that
happen
it's it's difficult you know so i so i i
completely get it i would have tackled
them
something out of rant but i would have i
would and and
and and the thing is like you know we we
we're not a community no more like we
just think about like
ourselves and [ __ ] you know like damn
you know
i have a family goal to go home to you
know
i don't want to get arrested i don't
want to get in trouble
you know like that happened to her like
you know i got to mind my business
well let me tell you this that happened
to her
on that block you know and you didn't do
anything we didn't do anything
that invites other people to come so now
next time it might be
your wife that's walking down that
street and somebody just wants to punch
her because
they saw that video where you just
didn't do anything and they're like
well you don't do anything anyway so let
me just take my frustration out on
some random women you know what i'm
saying and the more we see that we're
just like not doing anything about it
the more it's gonna happen and let me
tell you this
these asian attacks are not going to
stop
no time soon you know people be like oh
well
9 11 the muslims the muslim people had
bad you know there was a lot of tax on
them and
they got then it went you know
[Music]
yeah well
afghanistan didn't like pose as much of
a threat
as china does to america you know
so i don't think that threat is going to
stop anytime soon
and as long as that threat is like there
there is gonna be an anti-chinese
sentiment in our country
and people don't know how to
differentiate
chinese from korean japanese yeah we're
all the same
we're all the same and uh
we we have to start we have to start
changing some of this [ __ ]
you know i mean so for you what is
something that you would tell
like people what's like the next step
for them like because for me
the thing that i've always been kind of
putting out is
i don't dislike activism online
like that's cool that's one way to start
but saying something versus doing
something is completely different
yeah you can give lip service as much as
you want but when it comes down to it
like in those videos that's where it
becomes problematic right
like you gotta you gotta really like
stand up for yourself and really do that
like i say
words are fine action is way more
important
right you know whether you guys want to
figure out in whatever way that you want
like i said you don't
if somebody asked me what would you have
done in that situation i could probably
guarantee you a hundred percent
i probably would have sucked that down
right you know and that's not me just
saying it whatever
i can't watch right a woman who looks
like my mother get hit
and then not do something i've it's just
not possible in me
right so i would say number one
um
number one have a conversation with
yourself
and understand that you know we're under
attack
you know um
[Music]
number two i would say
to make the decision
to get your body in shape you know to
have confidence in your ability to
to to use to fight
to use your body you know uh and once
that confidence comes
in our ability then
you know we're more it's it's easier for
us to stand up
for certain things you know so i think
those are the first
two major steps start preparing
for altercations and i'm not telling
anybody that's like just go out there
and like
be like you know be a batman or anything
like that but
or like start fighting everybody for but
we do have to prepare right like times
of
of you know just
us just being able to just you know the
savior mentality is gone now
right basically like nobody's gonna come
and say nobody's gonna save you
you know you have to be the savior for
you for your family and for your
community
you know and we have to start looking at
that and i feel like this is something
that we all have to start doing and i
think
you just take those first two steps
things will start changing yeah cool man
well
uh yeah thanks for coming through man
this was a really super enlightening i'm
so glad you came through everybody has
been wanting you to be on this podcast
you know uh like one of my biggest goals
i think when i have conversation and
break bread i don't really have an
agenda
but uh i love the fact that you're on
the space man like i can't
stop repeating that enough that's why
when you when you said you were gonna
quit music
it was disheartening for me you know
because when i see people who
i personally can relate to a lot i need
you guys on these spaces right
because there's like i said there's a
community out there that needs your
voice
whether people agree or disagree with us
or not there is a space for us to be
here
you know it may not see be in the
biggest numbers ever
but the people that you do affect
individually it really does [ __ ]
matter
there's no that's the only reason why
i've been doing this for 11 years now
is if i didn't affect the people that i
affected then i wouldn't be doing this
for that long
right there's absolutely no [ __ ] way
you know so you know thank you for
coming through like tell everybody where
they can find you
oh you could find me on instagram
chinamac
uh youtube china mac tv my website is
chinamaconline.com
um and yeah that's where you can find me
and check him out
uh if you want to support him you can go
ahead and buy his music directly all of
his merch and everything else like that
make sure you uh
cop that [ __ ] support your favorite
artist and we'll see you all next time
peace